I think it's been a long enough time now
since a Mosin theatres since I'm in the
wasp was in theaters and since infinity
war was in theaters that we can talk
about the snap we could talk about the
big Thanos snap and how you feel about
being one of the half of the population
of the entire universe that just
disappears well first of all talking
about being kept in the dark
mm-hmm when we shot the scene I had no
idea that we were gonna go to the
quantum realm would disappear oh yeah I
had no idea and so when I saw the
theater we all I mean I would is that
the end of my character no more hate Pym
and then because I'm not quite up to all
of the films the Marvel films everybody
else in the explaining what was
happening with the Avengers and all of
that so yeah it's it's it's it's a
fabulous device huh mm-hmm
it's left a lot of people say my god
they wiped out half the Avengers
universe and one fell swoop what's gonna
happen next and you know what your guess
is as good as mine or Marvel's because I
mean they're scratching their heads
trying to figure it out right now so
you're telling me that no one is letting
you know about what's going on no thank
them next but they know who you are it's
not just me I'm telling you I think it's
most all of the characters this is this
is part of it they write themselves into
these things I I'm convinced that as far
as the ending of ant-man and the wasp
they were not sure until they kind of
figured it out with Avengers and other
things what the hell they were going to
do this is the this is the confidence
you get when you're 20 out of 20 20
movies that all have been successful and
you now trust your ability to wing it
the same thing with reshooting you know
most all the films and and they're very
smart about it built into their budget
that they they they screen the movie
then based upon quite
and everything else they reshooting to
answer the questions or what's not
working Marvel will do this right up
until you know breakfast right before
the premiere of the movie yeah so for us
we're not gonna sit in the mock theatres
to watch the open the premiere of
ant-man on the wasp it is the first time
I've ever seen anything you know other
than one thing other than watching a
green screen and it's fantastic yeah
it's fantastic I'm watching going do
this and so having a 50-year career
that's really been based upon
contemporary psychological thrillers no
green screens in my life this is a whole
new world which I find really
fascinating do you feel in a way new as
a performer doing this it's it's only
yeah totally totally new just a whole
new form from beginning to end just
realizing that you literally can do
anything yeah and I mean for me hank pym
kind of maintains the gravitas I try to
keep the plot line and everything from
like floating away so it doesn't get too
goofy goofy you know Sarah you need you
need that one person who's the guy like
the coach yeah on the team just story
storyline wise because everything else
is is so goofy goofy and I like that
rule now given that you can do anything
in these movies one of the big things
that everyone loved was seeing you in
your prime again yeah ant-man and you
the direction from you must have been
pretty amazing likes it more than I did
so now that we're dealing with you know
the quantum realm and possibly time
travel if you could put in your two
cents about what the next ant-man in the
wasp or ant-man movie would be would you
say you know put me in as a as a young
king young Hank Pym I like the
flashbacks I think it's important I
think we've established the fact Hank
Pym is one of the only Marvel characters
who has aged right
I mean we're playing him as an older guy
than the comics I don't know many any
other
just to have that effect we've sort of
introduced you know my my protege Paul
Rudd who was a petty thief you know I
don't think very much of and certainly
does not reflect the Ant Man of my
persona god forbid my daughter likes him
I don't get that at all
so I enjoy the fact of having this this
this role as the as the one character
actually has aged and we have this
memory and I get to play moments of
flashbacks of being a younger person to
remind the audience of the powers and
the strengths that I once had yeah so I
don't I don't I think it'd be crazy just
to make him young the whole way have you
and Catherine ever talked about the idea
of her joining into like it seems like a
great crew of people on these movies it
has I mean it's not my my position to
say you know I'm not a producer on this
on this film Kevin Feige Lewis Esposito
do an amazing job these guys are as we
said 24 20 yeah I've not missed yet I
would welcome Catherine if they decide
but there's so many other worlds to
bring in and yeah that would that would
be great but then she'd be away on
location for three months so you got
gotta figure out a way to be in it
together that's it yeah all wise you
just say I got a what I did I can do
this now we just you just been saying
you know these movies a 20 of 20 huge
hits and the Oscars this year you know
they had said they didn't want to see
like a popular motion pictures category
that people kind of put food in yes yes
yes but do you think that these movies
like Black Panther being such a
touchstone being such a popular movie do
you think that it's time to be
recognized by the Academy for your films
III don't think you should make a
category for most popular most popular
kind of films as if III don't that'd
just be littles everything you have an
equal Oscar misses its popular I mean
these pictures are huge financial
successes
thank you very much and a lot of these
Academy nominee pictures you know only
wish only wish their entire their entire
box office was one weekend one of the
Marvel Marvel films you know so it's
what it's May I mean come on you know
they're you're getting a lot of
attention phenomenal international
worldwide success if you don't win if
you don't want to ask your boohoo mm-hmm
you know now you've been a film producer
before and you've directed a little bit
they're always looking for fresh voices
here at Marvel in the MCU you ever think
you put a director's hat on and try to
take the reins of one of their big
pictures hi I dated I mean I really as I
watch Peyton Reed and what he went
through and and the managing of your
effects and having your visual effects
crew over your neck like this with the
with the boards and trying to match this
the complexities involved I I don't have
a mathematics degree to deal with Luthi
all of the elements that that come into
play here you you really it's it's it's
a unique kind of talent that I don't
think I possess mm-hmm so not the
science it's just just happy playing the
scientist then I'm happy I am so happy
to play the sciences and to to work on
my techno words and enjoy my green
screen you know and and and actually be
in supportive of Evangeline and Paul I'm
you know most of my career has been
carrying movies I'm like every scene of
most movies so this to me is like a
holiday random really a holiday III I
love doing it and and I love learning
this this whole world